The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So welcome
everybody, and I actually
used to be at MIT in the
'90s, so it's good to be back.
And so we're going to talk
today about a different kind
of security.
It's going to be less on the
technical mechanism side,
and more on the,
well, what happens
when all this technology gets
put in place in something
where there's high consequences?
Not quite so high-consequence
as, say, an airplane in
the sky, but getting
pretty close.
Just to let you know
where I'm coming from.
So I used to be part of the
midnight coffeehouse club
myself, but this is
Michigan, actually.
We're not quite as big
as your campus here.
But a short while
ago somebody decided
to put a hot tub on our
computer science building,
so they're doing
research inside there.
But what we're going
to talk about today
is some of the research
that bubbled out of that.
So we're going to
talk about everything
from exploding defibrillators
to other issues of privacy
in medical devices.
And this mainly is
going to be related
to just one thread of research
from one of my former graduate
students here, who is
actually at this point
sanitizing explanted pacemakers.
But we're going to mostly
talk about the security
of medical devices today.
Got a bunch of acknowledgements.
There it is on tape.
This work is by tons
of people, and I'm
going to try to
summarize for you some
of the modern bits about
medical device security
through all sorts of places.
I'm also required to
put up this boilerplate
slide of my potential
conflict of interest,
so now you can know about
any potential biases
on my thinking.
But I'd like to
think that I am less
biased than the average person.
OK.
So moving on.
So an interesting thing
happened about a year ago,
when FDA-- the Food and
Drug Administration--
released a draft document
saying they are now
going to be expecting
manufacturers to consider cyber
security-- or as we call
it, security and privacy--
not only in their implementation
of the medical device software,
but in their design
of their software.
Before a single line of
code has been written.
And so we're going
to talk about how
this has affected the
thinking in the medical device
manufacturing community.
Their final guidance came
out just a couple weeks ago,
and we just held
a conference call.
FDA held a conference
call, and over 650 people
decided to join
the teleconference.
So there's a lot of interest
in the manufacturing community
about how to take some of the
concepts you're learning here
in your class and actually apply
it to the medical community.
But it's really hard.
And I noticed one of the
questions up on the website
was about how to get the culture
change in the medical community
to understand security.
And this slide illustrates that.
So, who washed their
hands this morning?
OK.
Oh, this is not MIT, everybody.
So actually about
164, 165 years ago,
there was a famous
physician, Ignaz Semmelweis,
who was looking into something
called childbed fever.
And he discovered that
his medical students
who were working in the morgue
in the morning who later went
to work with patients,
well, those patients
tended to die more often.
And he discovered if you washed
your hands, then statistically
you were less likely to pass
on some kind of probability
of not living longer.
So he recommended that
physicians wash their hands.
And the reaction from
the physician community
was, doctors are
gentleman, and therefore
their hands are always clean.
And to some extent
we're seeing some
of those kinds of attitudes
toward security today,
so it's not too surprising.
But I'll try to
draw some parallels
with that throughout the talk.
I've got a lot of
material to cover
so I'm going to whip
through some things.
But first thing I'm going
to do-- anyone a physician?
No?
OK, well you're all
going to be able to have
some good material
for cocktail parties
with your doctor friends.
We're going to talk
a little bit about
implantable medical devices.
Actually I'll pass
this guy around.
You can feel free to touch it.
It's been de-dangered.
Just don't lick it.
This is a defibrillator
from a former patient.
And actually this is a device
here-- about 50 years ago,
some of the first pacemakers
started to appear on the scene.
They were external.
You had to have a burly
nurse to cart it around.
And then as the
decades wore on, they
became small enough
to be implanted,
completely implanted
in the body.
And here you see a
picture of what's
called a wand that's
using inductive coupling.
It's technically wireless.
There are no wires.
To wirelessly program the device
to be 60 beats per minute.
But interesting to me
as a security researcher
was that in around
2003 or so, we
began to see defibrillators,
such as the one I'm
passing around, that started to
embrace wireless technologies
and networking that
you'd be more used to
as sort of general computation.
And I was thinking what
could possibly go wrong?
Luckily there are a lot
of engineers also thinking
that same question in
companies, but security, it
takes a different mindset.
And I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
that mindset is changing.
So if you were to open up
one of those devices, what
you find inside are vast
resource constraints.
If you want a hard
engineering problem,
pop open one of these devices.
So about half of the
device is just a battery.
A very high quality battery.
These cost about $40,000
a pop on the market.
Silver vanadium oxide.
And you've got little
microcontrollers at the top.
Typically you have
some antennas where
you can do your communication
for your control of the device
as well.
This is all hermetically
sealed, implanted in your body.
We're talking one of the
harshest environments possible.
You want to recharge a battery
in your body, good luck.
Did you know that batteries
give off heat and gas?
So there are very
challenging constraints
to engineering the device.
When you want to add security,
it gets just a little bit hard.
So there is, however,
a very good reason
for having a wirelessly
controlled medical device.
There are good reasons, but
there are these subtle risks.
So to illustrate
that, I want you
to see what pacemakers
used to look like.
So this is a pacemaker
from the Medtronic Museum
up in Minneapolis.
And can anyone guess what
that little piece of metal
is on the right hand side?
What its function is?
Antenna?
Control?
Control is very close.
Any other guesses?
So this is a device before
there was wireless communication
to control a pacemaker.
In the old days, when you
want to change the settings
on your device, the
physician says, "Patient,
please lift up your arm.
I'm going to put a needle
through your armpit to twist
the dial to change
your heart rate. "
So one of the great
reasons for wireless
is that it actually
reduces infection rates,
because the more you put
foreign objects in your body,
the more likely you are
to contract an infection.
It is a serious risk.
Actually, 1% of implantations
have major complications,
and of those,
about 1% are fatal.
So controlling infection is one
of the most important things
you can do in the implantation
and changing of the device.
Of course, if you go the
other extreme and just say,
I want to put
wireless everywhere,
you'll get different
kinds of risks.
So I've sort of dubbed this
the bacon theory of wireless.
Now my mother's
from the Midwest,
so she used to say bacon
makes everything better.
And I've noticed there are
some device manufacturers who
seem to be putting wireless
everywhere without necessarily
thinking through all the risks.
It does have its
benefits, but you
need to very strategically
think before you add this
to a safety critical device.
What are the security
risks for instance that
are going to be opening up?
Oops, I had one
misplaced slide, but I
guess I'll just say it anyway.
I'm not going to talk a
whole lot about networking,
but I thought this quote was
just too good not to mention.
Does anyone remember the
ship off the coast of Italy?
The captain says,
"These days, everything
is much safer, thanks to modern
instruments and the internet."
And there's his ship
that turned over there.
So you add internet
connectivity and wireless
to your medical device, there
are going to be new risks.
And you don't need
to be afraid of them,
but you just need to have
appropriate mitigating
controls.
So I'm flying through this.
But what I want to
give you is paint
a picture of what's a typical
day in a medical device,
and how it's used
in clinical care,
and how that might
change your mindset
if you come from a
security background,
and how you think about risk.
So first going to
talk about the world
where there aren't real threats,
just unsafe practices and some
carelessness.
So the FDA maintains a database
of near misses, malfunctions,
injuries, and deaths.
This is all public.
You can go look
this up yourself.
It's called MAUDE.
And one of the devices was
called this volumetric infusion
pump.
This is a device that
infuses drugs into your body
through an IV mechanically.
And this patient died.
And if you look carefully,
it says one of the causes
was a buffer overflow.
I think you learned
about buffer overflows
in your first lecture.
So they are very real and they
happen and in every sector.
So in this particular case when
the buffer overflow occurred,
it was actually caught in their
error checking in the software,
but the action it took
was to shut the pump down.
To bring it down to a safe mode.
What they didn't realize
was that for some patients,
shutting down the pump is
basically a death sentence.
So this patient died
after the increase
in intracranial pressure,
followed by brain death because
of the buffer overflow.
So there's nothing really
complicated here, right?
You all know you don't
want to have buffer
overflows in your software.
There's no adversary
at this point.
So this kind of illustrates
the state of software, at least
for this particular device.
It's very challenging.
The other challenging
part that doesn't come up
a whole lot in a security
course is the human side.
So there are few
universities that
focus on the human element, but
I think there ought to be more.
So I set out on some life
experience of my own.
My wife asked to
remain anonymous,
so she said as long as
I don't reveal her name.
So that's me, that's our
infusion pump in the back,
and that's our baby in there.
And for us luckily the
pump worked just fine.
But pumps are great for
delivering medical care,
but they have resulted in over
500 deaths due to various forms
of malfunctions.
So I'm going to tell you
about one more malfunction.
There's also an
implantable kind of pump.
They're not just
bedside pumps, the kind
you see on daytime
hospital dramas.
But here's an implantable
pump, and it's
got this semipermeable
membrane where
you can replenish the drugs.
And this is a user interface
that the nurse or the clinician
uses to change the dosage rate.
So does anyone see where you
type in the quantity of drug?
You've got to kind
of squint, right?
So you squint really closely.
And one thing you'll notice
is here by number six
it says we're going to
dose this bolus-- bolus
is a quantum of drug-- over
20 minutes and 12 seconds.
We're going to dose
this into the patient.
And this is implanted,
so you don't feel it.
There's no nerve.
And this user
interface is actually
after an FDA recall
went into effect
for the software quality.
So what was missing before the
recall were eight key elements.
In particular HH:MM:SS.
So what do you think happens,
or what you think could happen,
if that label were missing?
It's really easy to
get the units wrong.
Make an order of
magnitude error.
So unfortunately for this
patient, who later expired,
he or she had his or
her pump reprogrammed,
and the health care
professional noticed
that the bolus was given over
20 minutes instead of 20 hours
after the fact.
Unfortunately the patient
left the facility,
got into a motor
vehicle accident,
and then later died after the
family removed life support.
But if you look at this from
a technical perspective,
the problem is
pretty simple, right?
In terms of you didn't
have the label there.
But human factors is
very easy to overlook.
It's not always right
there, front and center,
in the engineering process.
Do you have a human factors
part in this lecture?
See what I mean?
Blame Nickolai.
No, Nickolai is great.
But it's a very
important element
of improving the
trustworthiness of devices
that rely on software.
So I encourage you to think
about better human elements
and human factors
for your software,
even if it's on
something non-critical.
So that should begin
to paint a picture
of the typical problems
in medical device failures
post [INAUDIBLE] 25.
And the other thing
I want to talk about
is the exciting
world of management.
Management, exciting.
I used to collect all these
little dialogue boxes whenever
my computer would get
a software update,
but this all happens
in the background now.
Like my iPhone's
constantly getting updates
and drawing more power.
But now it just sort of happens.
But medical devices also
take software updates.
They're not really
fundamentally different from
traditional computing devices.
They just happen to control
vital functions of your body.
So there's an interesting case.
It's now been about four years.
So McAfee-- there are a
number of antivirus companies
that produce products
that hospitals use--
and in this particular case,
McAfee had this software
update that actually
misclassified
a critical Windows
DL as malicious,
and then decided to
quarantine the system.
So when it
quarantined, let's see.
[COMPUTER SOUND]
That always happens, right?
OK.
So, ha ha ha.
In this particular
case with McAfee,
when they quarantined
this critical Windows DL
as malicious, the machine
just started rebooting.
Blue Screen of
Death and cycling.
And in Rhode Island,
they basically
stopped admitting
patients at one hospital,
except for severe cases
like gunshot wounds,
because their admission systems
weren't working properly.
So clinical care depends heavily
on the function of software,
and we sometimes forget
about the role of security.
On the topic of depending
on other people's software,
Microsoft has one of the largest
footprint of operating systems.
And believe it or not, there
are a lot of medical devices
that run on Windows XP.
Windows XP, in case
you didn't hear,
went out of service
half a year ago.
So you should not be
using this, because there
are no more updates, security
updates, function updates.
It's antiquated software.
But there are still medical
devices today being shipped
brand new with Windows XP.
The software life cycles
are a little bit misaligned.
If you're used to downloading
updates for your open source
software on a daily basis, well,
think about medical devices.
You might not be able to
get to it, say, for a year.
It might be in the
field for 20 years.
So it's very difficult
to locate software
that's appropriate for
a 20-year life cycle.
It's basically flying in space.
So the Food and
Drug Administration
has now released some
guidance-- actually,
this was just
exactly a month ago--
on what they expect to
see from manufacturers.
Think of it as a design project.
As you're writing down
all the requirements
of your medical device,
they're asking manufacturers
how have they thought through
the security problems.
How have they thought through
all the security risks?
How are they mitigating it?
What risks are they
accepting as what
they call residual risk,
things that they don't solve?
But they expect them to least
be aware of all the risks
and ideally mitigate them.
So with the management
of software,
when no one person
is accountable,
all sorts of crazy
things happen.
But there is some
guidance now that's
beginning to emerge to help
the manufacturing community
to better integrate security
into their products.
So I think we're making
some pretty good time.
All right.
So now we're going to be able
to go into the security side.
I wanted to get the
non-security stuff out
of the way for the context.
So let's put on our gray
hats and black hats.
Before I begin this,
though, I guess
what I want to say is this
is a very challenging area
to do research, because
there are patients.
And if I were given a medical
device, for instance, today,
I'd still take it even if
the security problems weren't
all worked out, because
I know I'm much better
off with that medical device.
But that said, of
course, I'd prefer
to have medical devices
that are more secure.
So there is the emergence of
more and more secure devices,
but today, if you have to choose
between a device and no device,
I'd strongly
recommend taking it,
because you're going to be
in a much better position.
But that said, let's
take a look now.
If we consider the adversary,
and if the adversary
wants to cause problems
to a medical device.
So who's got the
defibrillator at the moment?
Oh, it's right over here.
Good.
So I'd like to tell you
a little bit about how
these defibrillators
are implanted.
This is a very special device
because, well, number one,
it's implanted, therefore
it's very high risk.
It's life sustaining.
If it's pacing your heart,
for instance, and it fails,
the results can be catastrophic.
So it's very interesting from
an engineering perspective.
It needs to work
24/7 for many years.
So this is a programmer.
Not a person, but a device.
It's basically a ruggedized
computer, and attached to it
is a little wand.
That's not a mouse.
That's a transmitter/receiver
speaking a proprietary wireless
signal over a licensed spectrum.
We're not talking
802.11, we're talking
specially-licensed
spectrum there.
And what happens is it
takes about 90 minutes.
The patient is
awake, just slightly
sedated to remain calm, and
there's a local anesthetic.
A small incision is made
beneath the clavicle.
And then the team--
typically it's
a team of about six people--
will weave electrodes
through a sacrificed
blood vessel that then
terminates inside the heart.
And actually I have
one of them right here.
This was not previously used.
You can pass this around.
You see the little
tines on the end.
And on some of the devices
there's both a sensor,
so it can sense
your cardiac rhythm,
and there's also actuation.
You can send shocks,
both small and large,
to either pace the heart or
to basically reboot the heart
if there's a chaotic rhythm.
It's a very highly
advanced device.
It's a steroid-tipped
piece of metal on the end,
so it doesn't bind
to the tissue.
You can pass that around.
It's basically a
USB cable, right?
So after that's
implanted into the body,
the patient is sewn up.
They do some testing.
And typically the
patient will receive
what looks like a
little base station.
Like a little access point.
It's very proprietary.
Typically they speak a
proprietary RF to the implant
so it can gather
all the telemetry,
so that it can send it back up
through the cloud-- typically
through a private cloud,
for whatever private means--
so that the health care
professionals can keep tabs
on their patient.
So for instance, if
you notice that there's
some odd measurement
coming from patient Mary,
you might call up
Mary and say, "You
should really make
an appointment
and come in, because I'd
like to see what's going on
with your defibrillator."
So one of the nice
things about the wireless
is they're able to have
more continuous care
rather than come back in a year.
We had a team of students
at several universities
get together, and I gave them
one of these defibrillators
and an oscilloscope,
and they went off
into a cave for
about nine months.
And they came back and
said, "Look what we found!"
So this is a screenshot of the
communication between a device
and the programmer.
And what you can see is first
of all, it's in the clear.
There's no cryptography, at
least none that we could find.
You'll find inside here the name
of the implanting physician,
the diagnosis, the hospital.
Basically a complete
electronic health record.
This is an older device,
from about 10 years ago.
But that was the state of
the art about 10 years ago.
There didn't appear to
be any use of encryption,
at least for the privacy
of the health information.
So when we noticed
this, we thought,
well then, we definitely need
to look at the security side
about how the device
is controlled.
How do they ensure the
authenticity of the control?
The integrity?
And that's when we decided to
do the following experiment.
So we started learning how to
use something called a software
radio.
Probably some of you have
played around with these.
There are a bunch of them now.
About 10 years ago,
the most popular one
was the USRP and
GNU radio software.
So we took an antenna from a
pacemaker that we didn't need,
created a little antenna, and
we recorded the RF communication
of inducing a
fatal heart rhythm.
And then we replayed
that communication back.
And then the device
happily emitted
a large-- something on the
order of a 500-volt shock.
On the order of about 32 joules
in one millisecond, which
I'm told if you were
to get that on you,
it's like being kicked
in the chest by a horse.
So it's a rather powerful shock.
And the interesting thing
was how we discovered this.
So I was in the operating
room, and recall back,
I said that when
you're a patient
and the procedure is
ending, the health care
team tests if the defibrillator
is working properly.
So how do you end-to-end
test if a defibrillator's
working properly if the
heart is beating normally?
Right?
So what's built into
the defibrillator
is a command to induce
the very fatal heart
rhythm that the defibrillator
is designed to restore you from.
It's called a command shock.
So when I asked the
physicians about that,
they didn't seem to understand
the concept of authentication.
And that's when we
decided we'd really
need to look more deeply into
how to solve these problems.
So in this particular
case, we were
able to send the
command to the device,
and we weren't authenticated,
and we could induce that shock.
The good news is
these devices have
been able to solve these
problems through some software
updates.
And they've been aware
of it for quite a while,
so they're able to
spin out devices
that now take into
account some of these more
adversarial conditions.
Where are those
tines going around?
Over there?
OK, great.
So that's the implant side.
There's a huge amount
of innovation going on
with implants.
It's not really science
fiction anymore,
but there are real people
and patients behind it.
And most people care deeply
about delivering quality health
care.
But sometimes they just don't
realize how to fit security
into their designing process.
So it's a challenge culturally.
Another stakeholder
are the people
who provide health care
in the first place.
Hospitals, primarily,
or small clinics.
If you want to find
malware, go to a hospital.
You're going to find
some interesting malware.
And here's why.
So here's a screenshot
from a colleague who
used to work at Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center
here in Boston.
And he gave a map of his
network architecture.
There's nothing particularly
earth-shattering
about the architecture.
What was interesting,
though, was
he listed the
number of operating
systems in his
hospital on what were
considered medical devices.
And I looked at him-- I like
to add up numbers and insanity
check things-- and I
said, "Well, you've
got Service Pack one, two,
three of Windows XP, zero
15 plus one.
That equals 16.
That doesn't equal 600.
Your addition's wrong."
And he looked at me and he
said, "No, Kevin, that's
600 Service Pack zero
machines in the hospital."
So these are medical
devices where
they've been unable to
get the manufacturer
to provide patches and update
it to the modern software.
Which means it's
that old software,
vulnerable to all the old
malware that's been hitting
Windows XP for 15 years.
So it's very difficult
in the clinical setting
to keep yourself protected,
because the product life cycles
are just completely out of sync.
They think in terms of
decades in health care,
but in the fast hockey stick
world of Silicon Valley,
we think about days, weeks, or
months for software updates.
You can see down here in
their clinical systems,
average time to infection
is about 12 days
when they don't have any kind
of protection against malware.
And they can get
almost up to a year
if they're able to get an
antivirus product on there.
But even that's not perfect.
And feel free to ask
questions too, by the way,
if you want to know more.
Go deeper dive on any
of these incidents.
But one of the
interesting things I found
was that one relatively
common source of infection
is the vendor themselves.
Sometimes they don't
even realize it.
So I'm going to go
over a few cases
where the vendor has
sort of accidentally
been the carrier of the malware.
I was talking with the
chief field security
officer for the Veterans
Administration, the VA.
They have about 153 clinics
in the United States.
And one day there was
a vendor showing up
to do software updates on
some of their clinical medical
devices.
And her intrusion
detection software
was just chirping
away everywhere--
I think his name
was Bob-- everywhere
Bob was walking and
plugging in his USB drive
to update the software.
He was infecting the machines
with malware by accident,
because somehow malware
got onto his USB drive.
So there's a
perception out there
that if you're not
networked, you're safe.
But if you think
about it for moment,
very few people used the
internet 20 years ago
and there were still
computer viruses.
So in a hospital, a
common infection vector
is the USB drive.
I'm even aware of
two manufacturers--
I can't tell you their
names-- but they almost
shipped malware-infected
medical devices.
And they caught it
by chance, by luck,
before it went out
into the product line.
Who's done any work
on the programming
with the cloud or
software distribution?
A few of you.
So the medical community is
also embracing the cloud.
It gives them more
distributive control.
But it also comes
with risks that
are qualitatively different
from your typical software.
If you want to get the
newest word processor,
that's one thing.
But if you want to get an
update for your ventilator,
completely different.
So I noticed there was
a recall on the firmware
for a ventilator.
And the manufacture sent out
a handy dandy website where
you could download an update.
Now I was going to go
check their PGP signatures.
Couldn't find those,
but what I did find
was a little link down here.
It says, "Click here for
your software update."
I thought, oh, goody,
let's go do that.
So I did that and up
popped this dialogue box.
It says, "Warning--
Visiting this site may
harm your computer.
This website you are visiting
appears to contain malware."
Has anyone seen this before?
Do you know what
it was what it is?
What's going on?
AUDIENCE: So that's probably
your antivirus software,
correct?
PROFESSOR: Close.
It's not my antivirus
software, but it's
sort of a similar concept.
In the back, I heard.
AUDIENCE: I would
bet this is Chrome.
PROFESSOR: Chrome.
Yeah, so in this case I
believe I was using Chrome.
But effectively
what's going on is
Google has something they call
the Safe Web Browsing service.
So actually, the guy who did
this is Neil [INAUDIBLE].
He's one of the lead programmers
for, I believe, OpenSSH.
He's actually from Michigan.
But he created this
service at Google
that goes around
the internet just
downloading random executables
and then running them.
And what's interesting is
they create a whole bunch
of virtual machines.
This is my understanding.
I may be misrepresenting
it, but my understanding
is they create a whole
bunch of virtual machines,
download those executables,
and just run it
and then see if the virtual
machine gets infected.
And if the virtual
machine gets infected,
you flag that website
as distributing malware.
They don't know the
intentions necessarily,
but it's a participant in
the malware distribution.
This is what you might
call drive-by downloads.
It's a very common
way of getting malware
to you on the internet,
especially with the spammers,
and some of the organized crime.
But in this case their website
appears have been infiltrated,
and instead of sending me the
ventilator software update,
they were giving me malware.
And at least according
to the Google website,
it says that over
the past 90 days,
that's what the website
was resulting in.
So all I could think
was, all right,
so if there's an FDA
recall, and you're
a biomedical engineer
working for a hospital,
and your job is to
keep your hospital
medical devices
safe and effective.
You're going to go
download that software.
So which box do you
think they clicked?
Do you think they
clicked close or ignore?
Right?
I am sure, I would bet you
dollars to donuts, 99% of them
clicked ignore.
Right?
And so all I'm
imagining now is we've
got thousands of
clinical engineers
and biomedical engineers
walking around with malware
on their laptops in hospitals.
Hopefully not on the
ventilator, but most likely
on their local computer.
So other fun things
you can do is
you can go search the
MAUDE database for keywords
like computer virus and
see what's in there.
And these are all
narratives submitted
by hospitals and manufacturers.
One of the more
interesting ones is
something called a compounder.
So I have one of
these in my lab.
It's kind of hard to get.
But it makes liquid drugs.
So it has I think on the
order of 16 ports on the top,
where you can have
the little serums,
and then it deposits
it into a saline bag.
And then you can use IV
delivery to deliver it directly
to your veins.
So many hospitals will
have these for custom, just
in time drug delivery,
special cocktails of drugs
for patients.
And what was
interesting is here,
there was a report
that the compounder
was infected with a virus.
OK?
So we bought that
compounder, and we found
it runs Windows XP embedded.
Surprise.
And so it was
vulnerable to malware,
all the malware that
any other Windows XP
box would be vulnerable to.
But what was a little
bit surprising to me
was manufacturer
response at the time.
I hope they changed their
tune, but at the time
they said, "Well,
we do not regularly
install operating system
updates or patches."
This struck me as whoa, what?
What do you mean?
I said maybe they
had a bit flip.
But there's a huge
misunderstanding
about expectations
of software updates.
Let me be clear.
FDA expects manufacturers to
keep the software up to date.
But many manufacturers
will claim
that they are not able to do
updates because of some FDA
nonexistent rules.
So if you ever run into a
medical device manufacturer,
and they claim that the
FDA rules prevent them
from doing software
updates, just
tell them, no,
actually that's untrue.
And Professor Freeman
created a poster for this.
So here we go.
"Homework prevents me
from passing class,
eHarmony prevents me
from getting dates,
and yes, FDA rules
prevent software updates.
Yeah, right.
Bull."
So it is true that issuing a
software update takes effort.
It takes engineering time.
It's not a simple process.
It's not like-- I don't know
what course it's called these
days, 6.170, what it's
become-- but it's not as simple
as typing "make" and then
submit to the auto-grader.
There's a huge amount of
verification and validation
that goes on.
But that's what
you're expected to do
if you're in the medical
device manufacturing game.
If you're in that industry,
that's the expectation.
So a question that
often comes up
is, do we need to
worry about this?
And are there any intentional
malicious malfunctions?
How significant are these?
And the good news is, I'm not
aware of any specific instance
where there's been
a targeted attack,
and I hope none ever happens.
But I think it'd be
foolish to assume
that bad people don't exist.
So if you look back in
history, in 1982, actually,
there was an incident in
Chicago where somebody
deliberately tampered with
extra-strength Tylenol
on the shelves of pharmacies
and inserted cyanide.
A number of people
ingested it and died.
A short time later,
at the funeral,
additional members of
family used the same bottle.
They also died.
Within days, the US
had pulled Tylenol
from all the shelves
in the United States.
You could not find Tylenol
And within one year, Congress
had passed new legislation
requiring tamper-evident
packaging and physical security
of over-the-counter drugs.
This incident is the reason
when you open up your medicine,
you see a little metal foil.
So we know bad people exist.
The cases that we are aware
of are more about tomfoolery,
but still dangerous.
So this woman said she had
one of the worst seizure she's
ever experienced
when somebody decided
to post flashing animations
on an epilepsy support group
website.
So quite malicious.
It was probably someone who
didn't realize the ramification
of their actions,
because you can actually
severely harm a patient who's
sensitive to those kinds
of things.
But again, bad people do exist.
So one of the problems
with the culture gap
is that much of medical
device manufacturing
thinks statistically,
and they think
about past performance
of a device predicting
future performance.
So in the security world,
we know that actually,
if you see no security problems,
that might be because there
are a bunch more to come soon.
So if you take a look at the
Mac, for instance, right?
Before two years ago, basically
no malware was on the Mac.
But then one night over
half a million Macs
got infected by Flashback.
So one of the problems is
bridging that culture gap.
To move from,
well, there haven't
been any reported
problems yet, so we
don't need to worry about it,
to explaining more about how
to fit security into
the risk management
thinking of medical
device manufacturing.
So hopefully we can
avoid this, and keep
that to be on the Weekly World
News, but it could happen.
So trying to bring
that analogy home now.
Before we get into a little
bit more on the solutions here,
is that way back when,
there was a lot of denial
that hand washing was a problem.
But there was a real
reason for that.
In the 1800s, running
water was not exactly
common in hospitals.
Latex gloves did not exist yet.
So to ask someone to merely wash
their hands for each procedure
was actually a
pretty tall order.
And the same thing can be
said of security today,
in almost any context.
There's no magic pixie
dust you can sprinkle.
There are no magic latex
gloves you can put to somehow
magically add security.
So when you ask a
manufacturer or clinician
to, say, keep your
device secure,
it's a pretty tall order.
So it's going to take
some time, I think.
But if they were
alive today, they
might be saying medical
devices should be secure,
and doctors are gentleman
and therefore their computers
are secure.
But I'm optimistic we're
going to get there,
because most manufacturers
I talk to now realize it's
a real problem.
They're just not necessarily
sure on what to do next.
So maybe they'll be hiring
you people for the future,
to help them solve
these security problems.
But what it all
boils down to is it's
very difficult to add
security on after the fact.
Bolting it on is
very challenging.
It's possible in some
cases, but it's really hard,
and often very expensive.
And you've really got to
design it in from the beginning
to get it right.
So FDA is expecting
manufacturers
to get it right
when they're still
working with pen and
paper, on whiteboards,
before they've
actually manufactured
the medical device.
So how are we doing on time?
Oh, quite a bit?
40 minutes, awesome.
OK.
I'm going faster than I thought.
Sorry if you're taking notes.
I'll talk slower now.
I want to talk a little
bit about technology
to make a medical devices
actually more trustworthy.
So I'm going to try to
blow your mind, all right?
So why do you trust the sensor
on, let's say, your smartphone?
You've got a smartphone there.
Do you know what sensors
are on that smartphone?
AUDIENCE: GPS.
PROFESSOR: There's GPS?
Accelerometer, I heard.
Any other thoughts?
What else would we
find on a phone?
AUDIENCE: Compass.
PROFESSOR: Compass?
Light?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR:
Electromagnetic field?
Everything's
temperature-sensitive.
Camera's technically
got a CCD sensor.
So there's sensors
all over the place.
Medical devices
have sensors, too.
Now, why do you trust
what the sensor's
telling your processor?
If you write software
and your sensor
tells you it's 77 degrees
today, or 25 Celsius,
why do you believe that?
So at least in my lab, we
do a lot of work on sensors.
So I try to pass
this one around.
This is a batteryless sensor.
It's got an MSP430
microcontroller.
But there's no battery.
It actually runs off a
10 microfarad capacitor,
and it harvests RF energy to
power up that microprocessor.
I'll pass it up
this side, I guess.
And it's got all the
fun little things
like a 3D accelerometer,
temperature sensors, light,
all that fun stuff.
But it's really
hard to power up.
But again, how do you
trust what's actually
coming into that sensor?
Something's translating it from
all these physical phenomena
to little electrical pulses.
So one thing I want
to highlight is
why you might not
want to trust what's
coming out of that sensor.
So this is work from one of
my post-docs, Denis Foo Kune
here, who's kiteboarding
on Lake Michigan.
But in his other
spare time, he likes
to interfere with sensors.
So let me tell you about--
forget security for a moment,
to safety-- there was a
gentleman in 2009 who reported
that every time his cell
phone rang in his kitchen,
his oven turned on.
So you can go find this
in the New York Times.
It just happened to be that
that resonant frequency was just
perfect to get that ignition
to go off in the over.
So there's interference
all over the place.
It's a constant battle, because
we have different devices
speaking in the same spectrum.
But there are technologies
to reduce that interference.
The problem is, what happens
when the interference is
in the baseband?
I'm going to go a little bit
analog on you for moment.
So does 6.003 still exist?
It does?
OK, good.
So I encourage you all to
take it if you haven't.
It's one of the most awesome
courses for a CS person,
because you don't have to
go too deep into the circus.
So what was
interesting to me was,
I was trying to understand
why I should believe
what a sensor's telling me.
And so I started to look
at the block diagram.
And so for instance, if you've
got a Bluetooth headset,
what you're going to find
inside that Bluetooth headset is
a microphone, piece of wire,
an amplifier-- right, 003--
some more wire, or
some traces on a PCB.
It goes to an
analog/digital converter.
There might be some filtering.
And then it goes to
your microprocessor.
But there's all this other
stuff that gets in the way
before it gets to your software.
And for some reason,
your software
just believes anything
this wire says.
So what was interesting to
me was, well, you know what?
That piece of wire from the
microphone to the amplifier,
it has a length.
It also has a
resonant frequency.
So what would happen if somebody
generates custom electromagnet
interference that's
optimized to latch
onto that resonant frequency
of that piece of wire?
Well, it would go
into the amplifier
and it would get amplified.
And then it would go into
that analog/digital converter,
and you'd pass onto
the microprocessor.
One of the questions we had
was, was this possible at all?
And if so, how hard would it be?
What kind of power
would you need to do it?
And what would be the quality
of the signal that actually
reaches the microprocessor?
So the fundamental reason
why this is even possible
is because we're talking
about intentional, as opposed
to accidental
interference, we're
throwing it into the baseband.
So here's an example.
Imagine that your
medical device is
designed to accept physiologic
signals in the low hertz.
Like your heart
doesn't beat that fast.
We're talking a
few hertz or less.
So if your electrodes were to
pick up some high frequency
signals, you'd just put
in some analog filters.
You'd say, that
cannot be real, right?
If your heart's
beating that fast,
you're probably just
picking up something
like an electric mixer while
you're making your lunch.
So similarly you can filter out
pulses in the high frequency.
But if you send interference
that's in the baseband,
those filters are going
to be meaningless.
Because those analog
filters cannot get rid
of if it's in the same frequency
area as what you're expecting.
So it's hard to
filter in the analog.
So I'm going to go
through a couple examples.
We're going to start
with a Bluetooth headset,
and then work our way
up to a medical device.
So Denis, he built a bunch
of homebrew dipole antennas
and transmitters and amplifiers.
Now what he's got up here is
you can see he's got a webcam.
I guess not too many of us
need to buy these anymore,
because they're built in.
But that webcam
has a microphone,
and then it's got
a little USB cable
to deliver the audio
to the computer.
So what he's done is
he's set up the computer
to record the video and
audio and then play it back.
So what's interesting
is-- you'll see this now.
He was in a completely
silent room.
It sort of sounded like this.
All you could hear was
the ventilation system.
He's got the camera.
He removed the housing,
just so it's easier
to tap in and measure
the interference.
And then he's got a
software radio about a meter
away, generating custom
electromagnetic interference.
He writes it in Python, and
then sends over his signals.
So here's what the
computer on the left
thought it heard, even
in this silent room.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC WEEZER, "ISLAND IN THE
SUN"]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So yeah.
The last time I did that,
somebody in the back
actually started dancing.
So it's actually
relatively high fidelity.
And it actually turns out that
in the manufacturing community,
they're so cheap.
They use really
cheap microphones
with poor frequency responses.
So we actually got
higher quality audio
through interference than
going to the microphone.
So if you ever don't like
your Bluetooth headset
and you want to play
classical music,
just do it with interference.
But don't tell the FCC
I told you to do that,
because you're not supposed to.
But the point is
if you're talking
intentional magnetic
interference,
it's kind of outside
the security model.
And so your processor
just trusts it.
So some interesting
things you can do.
Let's say your office
mate decides to call up
his bank to make some deposits.
Well, you can insert DTMF tones.
That's kind of fun.
So we were just playing around.
You can change the
language as the person's
trying to make deposits
from account to account.
But there's all
just interference.
And actually the person
on the Bluetooth headset
didn't hear it.
Because remember it's
coming from the person,
so that it doesn't actually
get echoed back to them.
But the bank heard it and
made all the transactions.
So there are ways to do this.
It doesn't take a whole
bunch of analog skills.
We're mostly
computer scientists.
But you do need
to somehow convert
the signal you want to have
appear at the microprocessor
into something else
that's easier to transmit.
So the first thing
you can do is think
about just
overwhelming the thing
with a very strong signal.
That's the brute force approach.
It doesn't work so well,
but it works a little bit.
So if you send something
out that matches
the resonant frequency of
that little piece of wire,
yeah, that'll get the
job done to some extent.
The problem is a lot of these
signals are low frequency,
and it's more
difficult to transmit.
It's got less power, basically.
So it's going to be
harder to send the signal.
So what you really want to do is
send a higher frequency signal,
and it's going to be easier
to deliver the power.
But if you send a really
high frequency signal, that's
going to be outside
the baseband,
so all the filters
are going to go at it.
So here's what you do instead.
You treat this circuit as an
unintentional demodulator.
So what you do is, we had
that original sine wave
we wanted to transmit.
Instead we modulate it onto
a higher frequency sine wave.
And we send it in
to the amplifier,
and eventually it's going
to work its way in because
of sampling theory.
You can think about
Nyquist and all that.
So up on the top is
the interfering signal
we're actually sending,
and then on the bottom
is what the microprocessor sees.
Because remember the
analog-to-digital converter
is not continuously sampling.
There's an interrupt
on the processor.
Wake up, take a reading,
wake up, take a reading.
So it's actually
going to sample,
and then try to
infer the signal.
So as we're sending out
our really fast signal,
it takes a sample,
et cetera, et cetera.
Your microprocessor thinks it
got this nice low frequency
sine wave, but we actually
used a high frequency one,
because that allowed us
to transmit more easily.
So I'm not going to go through
all the nitty-gritties,
but one another kind
of cool way to do
this is to muck around with
the non-linear components
of the circuit.
But this is all about violating
security models, right?
So we're completely violating
what the circuit designer
had intended.
It turns out that
if you send in, say,
in this case you're
sending in 826 megahertz
is the resonant
frequency of our wire.
But I can't speak that fast.
So what we do is we modulate
our voice on an 826 megahertz
carrier.
Problem is it's going to
get, for instance, all
this replication of the signal.
You're going to
see the frequency.
Here we're looking
at frequency domain.
It gets repeated.
But it turns out because
of the filters built
into most of these
devices, it's actually
going to chop off
the repeated copies.
So the end of the day, what
the microprocessor sees
is our original 1
kilohertz signal
we were trying to send in.
It's been unintentionally
demodulated.
So that's the easiest
example that I've
been able to come
up with to explain
the idea of this
intentional interference.
And now we're going to try
to apply it to defibrillators
and medical devices.
So again, the defibrillator's
implanted into the clavicle.
And it has these electrodes--
you can kind of see them here--
that go into the
chambers of the heart,
and it's used for both
sensing and actuation.
So it's just a signal.
So this is the time domain, and
this is the Fourier transform,
effectively.
So this is a single
heartbeat, and the heartbeat
is actually quite intricate.
The physicians have
actually labeled
the different components
of the heart rate.
You've got the
QRS complex, which
is typically what you would
think of as the heartbeat.
The actual beat is
this giant R here.
That's the one you'll feel.
But there are also these
other smaller waves,
as your tissue is
energizing and relaxing.
So if do a Fourier transform
on your cardiac rhythm,
you're going to end up
with most of the signal
in the tens of hertz.
You're not going to
see things a whole lot
beyond 100 hertz in a
typical cardiac signal.
So most of these
devices are designed
to filter out things that are
really low frequency or really
high frequency.
But if you choose to insert
intentional electromagnetic
interference on the
baseband, then it
gets through all the
analog circuit filters.
And now the only
approach to [INAUDIBLE]
that would be things more on
the computer science side.
So this is where
my students began
to have a little bit of fun.
So we wanted to test this
in as realistic a situation
as we could.
We couldn't get volunteers.
So instead we discovered there's
actually a national standard.
This is a body.
This is you.
It turns out that we're all
just bags of saline solution.
And so if you have a highly
calibrated saline solution,
that's the best way to
simulate human tissue.
The other thing we've done is
we used the synthetic cadaver.
She's actually
anatomically correct.
She's got all the
same vital organs
as anyone else
would have inside,
and a working
circulatory system.
So it has all the surface
properties of the RF.
So here we're doing
radiation fluoroscopy
to do 3D imaging-- 4D.
We see light imaging as we're
implanting the electrodes
into our synthetic cadaver.
So what we're going
to do now is generate
some electromagnetic
interference
and then try to see what
the device is perceiving
as a trustworthy signal.
So a couple ways we did this.
In the saline solution, we used
just a spool of magnet wire.
Here we have the wand that's
reading out the telemetry
to see what the device
thinks it's seeing,
and then another
experimental case.
So I had some leftover
pipes from plumbing,
so we created a dipole antenna.
And on the back there
on that poster board,
we created a 2D
version of a patient.
You can see that's the curvature
of the electrode, that's
the electrode, and
then the pacemaker
is right underneath the tape.
And we're transferring to it.
So here's what the
device thought it saw,
even though it wasn't happening.
So keep in mind this should have
been a flat line, because there
is no patient.
There is no heart beating.
So we tried a couple different
signals of interest are we
pulsed a sinusoid.
So that's really a
sine wave, but it's
so fast you can't quite tell.
But we pulsed it
like a heart beat.
So every one second
we sent out a pulse.
And then we also did
one that's modulated.
That's a little bit noisier.
So this is a screenshot of
the pacemaker programmer
which tells us live what
telemetry is going out.
And it's hard to read, but
the little green up there,
VP, says that the device sent
out the ventricular pace.
This is the pacemaker sending
an artificial heartbeat,
basically, to make
the tissue contract.
What's interesting
is when we started
sending our interference,
it got what's
called a VS, a
ventricular sense.
The little purple VS,
there's three of them.
So the pacemaker thought
that the heart was
beating on its own, so it
chose to inhibit the pacing
to save power.
And then when we turned
off the interference,
the pacing began again.
Similarly over here you see
where the interference starts,
and it's sensing
ventricular sense.
It says, oh, the body's
pacing itself naturally.
I don't need to waste my
energy pacing the heart.
So we're able to induce
that interference,
and then trick
the microprocessor
into believing the long state.
There is a silver
lining, though.
The good news is, that
only works in vitro.
Whenever we would do
this in saline solution
or in anything that
approximated the body,
it basically didn't work.
And that's because
your body absorbs
a lot of that RF energy,
and it doesn't actually
get to the sensor.
So the closest we were
able to get this to work
was, with the saline,
like three centimeters.
So that basically
means there's no worry
for this particular kind of
interference from an implant.
However, an externally
worn device, we don't know.
We hadn't done any tests
on insulin pumps yet.
There are plenty
of different kinds.
There's glucose
sensors, for instance,
that are percutaneous.
I wouldn't be surprised
if someone here has one.
They're pretty common.
But we just don't know yet.
But one of the approaches
we're taking to solve this
follows the end-to-end
principle to some extent.
A lot of these, I
just don't think
the analog is able
to distinguish good
from bad signal.
And so you have to do it closer
to the application layer.
So one of the defenses that we
tried out was the following.
It has its own limitations,
but here's the basic idea.
So imagine you're a pacemaker,
and you want to know,
are you getting a
trustworthy signal?
So what you do is
you selectively
choose to send test pulses every
now and then, to basically keep
the adversary in check.
So here's the interesting thing
we discovered when we worked
with electrophysiologists.
We learned that if you
send a pacing pulse
to a heart that recently was
beating, within about 200
milliseconds, that cardiac
tissue is physically
incapable of beating again.
It's also physically
incapable of sending out
an electrical
response, just because
of the polarization-- the way
that cardiac tissue works.
So we said, so what would happen
if we send an extra pacing
pulse right after a
ventricular sense?
He said, oh, well,
if the heart actually
had beat, as your
sensor told you,
then you should get no response.
Because it would be incapable
of sending a response.
So therefore, if we
saw the heart send us
an electrical signal
back, we knew-- then
that proves to us
that we were fooled
on the previous heartbeat.
And there we raise
our warning signs
that it appears to
be we're getting
intentional electromagnetic
interference.
So the basic idea is,
again, we probe it,
and we make use
of some of what we
know about the
physiology of the body
to have better trustworthiness.
Another approach we didn't
look into too deeply
was looking at
propagation delay.
Because if you have
electromagnetic interference
coming at you, it's
basically light, right?
Speed of light.
And if it's hitting you all at
once, if you have two sensors,
and you simultaneously see
the same cardiac signal
at the same time,
something's wrong.
Because there's an
electrochemical propagation
delay from your vagus nerve
as the electrical signal
is traveling down
through your heart.
So there are other ways
to try to tease out
whether the physiologic
signal is trustworthy,
but this is new ground.
There's not a lot going
on in this space yet.
A lot of fun projects for
graduate and undergraduate
research.
We end at-- oh, 25?
Oh.
So I want to tell you
about another project,
and that is detecting
malware at power outlets.
So a few years ago, one of
my students, Shane, he said,
hey, I built this power
outlet, and I can tell
what website you're browsing.
So he put a little
sense resistor in here,
and he measures what's
called the phase
shift in the reactive power.
It's basically a proxy for
the load on your computer.
And he can basically tell
how your computer-- how
your processor is
changing the load as it's
going out onto the
AC power system.
This is not new.
Has anyone heard of Tempest?
Tempest protection?
A few of you.
So Tempest has been
around for years.
Basically signals leak
all over the place,
and so there's a whole fine
art to stopping signals
from leaking.
What was interesting
to me was, I
like to keep all my old
computers-- actually
I have an exokernel machine.
And it's an old-- I
think it's a Pentium 4.
And this was before there was
advanced power management.
So if you measured the power
coming out of this old Pentium,
it was constant.
Just doesn't matter if
you were doing anything.
If you have a spin while
loop, doesn't matter.
It's the same thing as
actually doing processing.
But if you buy a modern
computer, whether it be desktop
or phone, your workload is
being revealed over the power
line in subtle ways.
And so what he discovered was
that what's going on here.
If you have an
embedded system that's
very difficult to change, and
you want to retrofit security
onto it, what you can do is
put in basically a power strip.
An intelligent power strip.
And it uses machine learning
classification of the frequency
domain.
Actually looking at the
frequency components
of your power consumption.
It's not looking at how
much power you consume.
Instead it's looking at how
often do you consume it.
So let me give you
some intuition here.
So imagine you have
a medical device that
gets infected by malware.
Let's say this malware is going
to wake up every few minutes
to send out spam.
How might that change
the power consumption?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, every few
minutes that interrupt's
going to go off, and the
processor's going to wake up.
It's probably going to
power up its memory.
It's going to do some
cycling, or it might actually
insert a few extra
cycles in what
used to be a very constant
set of instructions.
Medical devices generally
do a small set of things,
as opposed to a general
purpose computer.
So it's a very regular pattern.
So when you suddenly
have malware getting in,
it just changes the behavior of
its power consumption patterns.
So you can pick that up.
You do a Fourier transform.
You do some other magic
involving machine learning.
The devil's in the details.
But you can basically
use the machine learning
to identify with very high
precision, very high accuracy,
low false positive,
low false negative,
the presence of malware
and other anomalies.
And so that's a project
he had been working
on for a number of years.
He initially created
this project, though,
to identify what website
you were browsing.
And unfortunately, he submitted
it to a bunch of conferences,
and they all said, well, why
would you ever want to do that?
But it's kind of interesting,
because he picked the top 50
Alexa websites.
And then he profiled
his computer,
used that as a training set
for the machine learning,
and then again, with very high
accuracy, very high precision,
was able to identify which
website you were going to.
And we were really confused
why it worked at all.
And we still don't
know exactly why,
but we have some strong hunches.
And [INAUDIBLE] Drupal.
So there's been a movement
over the last 10 years
on websites to move from-- who
still writes in Emacs HTML?
All right, me too.
That's why I have all these
mistakes on my website.
But there has been a
large movement, especially
in institutions, to have
code automatically generate
a web content file that follows
a very regular structure.
So can you imagine
if you go to CNN.com,
and they always have an ad in
the upper right-hand corner,
with flash animation that
lasts exactly 22 seconds?
So your GPU might kick in
at a very regular rate.
So some very interesting
things bleed through
into the power consumption
patterns from the web browser,
and from other things in
your operating system,
as a result of your activity.
The only website we couldn't
classify too well was GoDaddy.
We still don't know
why, but we don't care.
So this is going to branch
a little bit further out
from the security side.
But one of the
things you find is
that when you're helping your
colleagues in the hospital
system, they often ask
back for some of your help.
And one of the
interesting projects
that we got involved
with, purely by accident,
from some of the
pacemaker security work
was in some humanitarian
aid in developing countries,
especially Ghana, to
give patients new life.
Literally new life,
because it turns out
if you don't have a
health care system,
it's very difficult
to, say, get a $40,000
pacemaker plus
the surgical team.
Very challenging.
So what they've been
doing is they've
been recovering discarded
pacemakers and defibrillators,
and then sterilizing them.
It's actually
pretty interesting.
You have to use-- well,
you don't have to--
but what's typically
used is ethylene oxide.
It's a gas chamber to
sterilize and remove
all the pyrogens,
things that cause fever.
But these devices
are sterilized,
and then reimplanted
in patients.
So here's a gentleman.
I believe he was suffering
from a slow heart
rate, which was basically
a death sentence for him.
But because he was able
to get a pacemaker,
it gave him extra years of life.
So the problem they
came to us with was,
how do they know if the
devices are still safe?
They weren't even used.
So obviously you can
look at the battery life.
So that's one thing you do.
And if the battery
is too low, you
would not reimplant it, because
that wouldn't last too long.
But then what about some
of the other things?
Has some of the metal corroded?
How do we do an end-to-end
check to see if you can still
detect arrhythmias properly?
So the students in my lab
created a special tester
that sends out
what you would see
from the electrical components
of cardiac arrhythmias.
Things other than sinusoid.
Cardiac rhythms that you
wouldn't want to have, right?
So, anomalies.
And it replays these
against the pacemaker leads.
The pacemaker thinks it's
connected to the patient,
and then it responds.
And so we check
that response to see
if it's actually diagnosing
the cardiac arrhythmias,
and whether it's actually
sending out the lifesaving
shocks properly.
So they're now starting to
test this through the whole FDA
process to get their blessing.
And that's a work in progress.
But it's called the My
Heart Your Heart program.
You can go look it up if
you're curious about it.
And then we also
interact quite a bit
with the medical device
manufacturing community.
We bring them in each
summer out to Ann Arbor,
and we have the
manufacturers sit down,
while some of the persons
who are in charge of running
hospitals sit down
next to them, and they
start sharing their gripes and
problems with medical devices.
We had one company come in and
just reveal all the problems
that none of the
people would respond to
at the medical
device manufacturer.
And one guy in the corner
was like, that's my team.
And so they decided to go
out for lunch, have a beer,
and just work out the problems.
So a lot of it is cultural.
So I don't know if anyone here
has done any security analysis
work, or reverse engineering.
Anyone here?
Couple people.
So it's really delicate.
It's almost an
art, because you're
dealing with the social elements
of the manufacturing side.
And it's even more so in
medical device manufacturing,
because lives are at stake.
And so it can be
very, very tricky
to share these kinds of
problems with the people who
are most able to fix it.
So it often results
in in-person meetings
and actually going
to their facilities.
So I want to save
some more time here.
Hopefully we'll
have some questions,
because I think we have
five or 10 minutes.
But I want to dispel
a couple of myths.
You'll hear a lot of newspaper
headlines and TV shows
talking about hackers
breaking into medical devices.
Let me say it is a problem,
but it's not the problem.
It's not the only
problem, and it's probably
not the most
significant problem.
And it's hard to say
that, especially when you
enjoy doing security analysis.
It's hard to say that,
because there's actually
two problems that I
think are more important.
One is preventing wide-scale
unavailability of patient care.
Because forget adversaries--
what if you just
have malware that
accidentally breaks
into a medical device
in a monoculture
where they're all running
the same operating system?
What happens when you
lose 50,000 infusion
pumps all at once?
It's very difficult to
deliver patient care.
One of my colleagues wrote to me
saying that his cath labs were
shut down.
Catheterization lab is a
relatively new specialization.
It's a special kind
of operating room
for minimally invasive surgery.
And at his hospital,
they had to shut down
the cath lab, because
turned out a nurse
had accidentally
brought in a USB stick.
Something about transferring
family photos up to Yahoo.
And somehow malware
had gotten in
and infected their cath labs.
So they had to shut
the thing down.
So if you're waiting
to get an angioplasty,
that particular center's
not available to you.
You'll have to use one
of the backup centers.
So availability is, I think, one
of the key things that is often
forgotten about in security.
Second one is the
integrity of the sensor.
So if your medical
device gets infected
by malware, or any kind
of malicious software,
things are going to change.
Things are going
to change in a way
that the designers
didn't anticipate.
So a very simple example.
Let's say some malware
gets in, and adds a timer
to every now and then wake
up, send some network packets,
and send out some spam.
This took some time.
Well, what happens if your
medical device assumed
that it had complete control
over the interrupt handler,
and suddenly now it's
missing interrupts?
Maybe the sensor has
some data to supply
to the medical device, but
because of the malware,
it missed the interrupt.
You may actually start
misdiagnosing patients now,
because that device is going
to be getting bad data.
So I'm very concerned
about the integrity
of the medical sensors.
There was actually a reported
case of a high-risk pregnancy
monitor getting
infected with malware
and giving out
incorrect readings.
The good news is a
highly-trained clinician
can look at the device and
say, that makes no sense.
That's not a sane number coming
out of my medical device.
But we're basically cutting
down the safety margins
when we can't have the integrity
of our medical sensors.
As I mentioned, very
difficult to bolt on this
stuff after the fact.
You think changing software's
hard on an internet scale?
Try it on a medical device.
So I met a guy from one
hospital where his MRI is still
running on Windows 95.
I have a pacemaker
programmer that runs on OS/2.
And they recently
upgraded to Windows XP.
So they have some really old
stuff out there, so changing
things for security after the
fact is going to be difficult.
Not impossible, but difficult.
And the other reason
is the interruption
of clinical workflow.
If you ever go off
and want to start
implementing medical
devices or doing something
security related
for health care,
I encourage you to go off
and call up some people,
and say, hey, can I go
into your operating room?
That's what we did.
Because you'll see some
weird things happen.
I took all my students to live
surgery, pediatric surgery.
And as they were
watching the surgery,
they were watching one
clinician checking Gmail
on one of the medical devices.
And they're like, oh OK, so,
drive-by downloads, check.
At the same time, they
wanted to calm the patient,
so they logged into
Pandora to play music.
Actually I was just at
my dentist the other day,
and she was playing Pandora.
And these ads for various beers
started coming up on the screen
as she was looking
at my dental x-rays.
And I was trying to figure
why Dos Equis was on my-- I
was like, did I drink that much?
She's like, no, we
just play Pandora here.
It's the same web browser,
and just click here.
So there's a lot
of mixing going on.
Maybe it's not malicious,
but it's opening cracks.
It's out of sight, out of mind.
The hand washing
sterile technique
is driven into the mindset
of anyone who's a clinician.
Wash your hands.
Don't touch the gloves
after you put them on.
But when it comes
to security hygiene,
it's really out of
sight, out of mind.
It's not part of
the culture yet.
They don't even
realize they should
be asking these questions.
Should I be running Pandora
on the same device that's
controlling my x-rays?
So but the important thing
is on the designer side
is not to interrupt
the clinical workflow.
Because that's when
mistakes happen.
You want to keep the
clinical workflow
regular, predictable, easy
for them to make decisions.
And if you add a new dialogue
box to enter a password, what
do you think a problem could
be in the operating room
if you ask the clinician
to enter a password, say,
every ten minutes?
Distractions?
You're sitting there,
doing this, right?
Scalpel.
Oh, yeah, let me walk
over here and type in my
pass-- oh, no, I
got my gloves on.
Let me take those off.
Oh, I've got to resterilize now.
Nurse!
So if you're a
security engineer,
you have to take into
account all the rather
special conditions of the
clinical setting with infection
control.
Which, surprisingly, not
everybody knows about.
There are definitely some
very talented engineers who
know about it, but not enough.
The other big problem
is I've noticed
that security people tend to
specialize in the mechanisms
to control security.
You can wield crypto.
I know CBC mode this, and I
know public key crypto this.
That's great.
And you know how to
prevent the problems.
You know how to
detect the problems.
The issue is from
the medical world.
Most people in the
medical world are
coming from a very
different mindset, one
that's called risk management.
Let me try to explain it.
In risk management, you
look at risks and benefits,
and you ask yourself,
do they balance?
If I take an action, does that
improve my risk management
outlook?
So if you're going to
decide, for instance,
am I going to deploy
a password system
on all my medical devices.
A security person
might say, duh,
of course you're going
to deploy passwords,
because you need
to authenticate.
The safety person might
say, well, wait a minute.
If I required we have
passwords on every system,
we're going to worry
about sterilization.
How do we know how
often to time out?
And what about emergency access?
What if we forget the password?
We want to make sure we can get
a response time in 30 seconds.
So they might actually
make a different decision.
They might actually decide
not to have passwords at all.
Actually many hospitals
don't have passwords.
Excuse me, many hospitals
don't have access control
on medical records.
Instead they have what's called
audit-based access control.
After the fact, if you look
at something you shouldn't
look at, they come get you.
Because they know that it's
very difficult to predict what
you're going to
need in your routine
of your clinical workflow.
So the risk
management kind of way
will depend upon deploying
the security controls
and all the technology
learn about.
But in the risk
management picture,
you might actually decide
not to deploy something,
because it could cause
harm somewhere else.
But trustworthy
medical device software
is going to require both.
So I'll just finish up here.
I think there's a lot of
interesting things to do.
So you're taking this
cool security course.
I encourage you to go
out and use those tools.
But as you're thinking about
where to go afterwards,
whether it's industry
or graduate school,
think about medical devices,
because they need your help.
They need a lot of
smart people there.
And so there's just one
thing missing-- you are.
And I think there's a
lot of interesting stuff
still to be done.
So I think we have five
or 10 minutes or so.
I'd be glad to take
some questions.
Or I could go more into depth.
I got some fun
videos I could show.
But I think I'll at least
take a break for a moment
to see if you have
any questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So that
pacemaker or whatever
it was that you were passing
around, does that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh,
the defibrillator.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How does that
interact with the fact
that they are [INAUDIBLE]
these kind of things.
PROFESSOR: OK so
a couple things.
So there are defibrillators
and there are pacemakers.
They're very related.
This is a defibrillator.
It sends out large shocks.
Pacemakers send
out small shocks.
But in the US, it's
illegal to reimplant these.
So it doesn't matter if you can.
It's just illegal.
But in many developing
countries it's not illegal.
And if you look from--
let me back up a slide.
If you look from not the
control mechanism, but the risk
management side of
equation, it might actually
lead to better public
health outcomes
to allow reimplantation and
reuse in developing countries
where they have no other choice.
And this is not my project.
This is just a project
we're assisting on.
But in that particular case, the
patients really have no choice.
It's basically a death sentence.
To sterilize it
is pretty tricky.
There's a whole lot of
science and engineering
that goes into how
to properly sterilize
to get rid of the pathogens.
Because these were in blood,
so first abrasive cleaner,
but the ethylene
oxide is one way
to destroy most, if not
all, of the pathogens.
There's a whole
testing procedure.
You actually put
special little-- I
forgot what they're called.
They're little wafers-- with
known quantities of pathogens.
And you put it in alongside
some of the devices
as it's going into the chamber,
and when you pull it out,
you test to see if all those
organisms have been killed.
Did that answer
all your questions?
You had a follow up.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what you're
saying, integrity of sensors
is a bigger risk
for hacker attack,
because most of the examples of
sensory interference you showed
are intentional interference.
So it's kind of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, so
the question is
why focus on integrity of
sensors rather than hacking,
because everything I
showed was about hacking?
That's selection bias.
I selected those cases,
but that doesn't mean
that's statistically relevant.
I divided up into two
cases-- maybe three.
The past, the present,
and the future.
So at the present,
most of the problems
we're seeing from malware in our
very rudimentary surveillance
of medical devices has to do
with malware that accidentally
gets in, and then causes
near misses and malfunctions.
But we're no dummies.
We know that there could
be an intentional adversary
in the future.
They just haven't
materialized yet.
The closest example
would be-- this
is just from the news reports.
I don't know if
it's true, but it
was from I believe
the New York Times--
that there was a hospital.
CHS, I think, was
the hospital, Where
they brought in a security
company, Mandiant.
And they believe that a nation
state had actually come in
to steal the medical records.
They don't know exactly
why, but nation states.
And nation states are
powerful adversaries, right?
If you run up against
a nation state,
you might as well just give up,
because none of these controls
are going to help you.
But here's my concern.
If the nation
state, for instance,
is very dedicated on getting
one piece of information,
what if they make--
they're human too, right?
What if they make a
mistake along the way
and accidentally
hit a medical device
as they're trying to extract
whatever kind of information
they're trying to get at?
And that could
affect the integrity.
In the future, there could be
instances of custom malware,
but I think it takes that
one more step of someone
really wanting to cause harm.
And I'm hoping that
there aren't too many
of those kinds of people.
But there are people
who write malware
who don't realize
that malware gets
into medical devices
in hospitals,
and it's still causing problems.